Here's a cut and sew pillow that's fast,
fast, fast, and you can finish it in an
evening.
We often think of cut 'n sew
for necklines in full garments.
It's a great technique for odd shaped
pieces like this heart pillow as well.
Working the stripes and shaping with
increases and decreases just didn't sound
like fun to me.
So I just knit some yardage.
Played with the stripes, cut out the shape
and put my serger and sewing machine to
work.
Let's get started.
I've used the Knit it Now 14 inch pillow
template, used some scrap fabric and made
a quick pillow form.
I believe you can find heart-shaped
pillows ready made, but I was in a hurry
as always.
As with everything knitting, the
project starts with a swatch.
I've determined that my gauge is four
stitches and six rows to the inch.
Armed with my gauge, I now know that to
knit a 14 inch square to make my pillow,
I'll need to cast on at least 56 stitches
and I'll have to knit at least 84 rows
total.
Now I've cast on a bit more to
give myself some seam to play with.
I'm knitting stripes, but you could use
any stitch pattern that's part of the fun
of cut 'n sew.
You don't have to worry about
shaping while working in pattern.
What about planning out the stripes?
Well, I've been known to meticulously
plan out stripes and use the Fibonacci
sequence, but this time I threw caution to
the wind and just changed colors randomly.
What do you think?
Now that I've knit the squares, I'm going
to give them a good steaming to set the
stitches and take out as much as
a curl along the edges as I can.
Since this is an acrylic yarn, I won't set
the iron down or kill the fabric, although
for a pillow, maybe it wouldn't hurt.
Next I'll draw around the template and
then serge and cut around the heart shape.
Before I start serging, I'm going
to snip here to the cut line.
Right at this point of the heart, this'll
make it easier to serge the shape.
We'll reinforce this
little area in a minute.
If you don't have a serger user sewing
machine and stitch a single straight
stitch around your Mark, and then two
rounds of zigzag or a stretchy stitch,
varying the width of that stitch to secure
the edges and then cut out the shape.
If you haven't done this before, just
take a get deep breath and go for it.
If you're really a scaredy cat, test
this out on your swatch first to get
confidence.
I'm using a serger that has a differential
feed, so I won't be getting an ugly
lettuce edge.
Be careful and test your serger stitch
settings first so you don't end up with
this.
Here are my pieces
straight off the serger.
I might use a shot of steam
to flatten them or maybe not.
This point of the heart's going to be the
most fragile, and I'm going to take time
to reinforce that point
with the zigzag stitch.
This'll be hidden in the seam so
you don't have to be too careful.
Just secure that area so those
center stitches won't pop out later.
Are we ready to assemble ? With the public
sides of the pieces facing each other pin
them together or run a quick basting
stitch by hand to secure the edges,
join them together, and sew up the heart
shape, leaving an opening of six to eight
inches to insert the pillow form.
Once you get everything all
settled, close up that opening.
I like to use the yarn
to close up the opening.
Use a combination of a whip
stitch and a back stitch.
Whatever's going to keep
that opening secure.
And that's it.
This is a quick, fun, colorful project to
celebrate Valentine's day or anytime you
want to send a hug to someone.
Now that we have a little experience and
we're not afraid to cut, let's think about
making a whole garment with cut 'n sew.